На першому навчальному курсі, я нічого не знав
ані українською, ані російською. Все було вперше.
Тільки знав «здрастуйте» і «спасибі».
Життя в Луганську було проблемним.
Там люди не дуже хороші.
У них викликає агресію вже навіть те,
що ми розмовляємо англійською.
[англійською] Я досі пам'ятаю, як вперше потрапив до Ужгорода,
люди дивились на мене так, ніби я з Марсу.
[англійською] Дивились з зацікавленістю: «Хто це?»
[англійською] Тепер я не безіменний, тепер мене знають.
[англійською] Люди кажуть: «О, це той індійський
фотограф, який чорно-білі світлини робить»
[англійською] Тепер мене знає багато людей.
[англійською] 6 місяців я робив фото
і працював в видавництві газети.
[англійською] Я писав для них статті на різні теми.
[англійською] І 6 місяців я працював в модельній агенції.
[англійською] Я досі роблю фото і 6 рік вивчаю медицину.
[англійською] І після кількох років навчання вважаю,
що це ідеальне поєднання: фото і медицина.
[англійською] Перша можливість фотографувати з'явилась,
коли проводили конкурс «Міс медичний факультет».
[англійською] Я працюю як фешн-фотограф,
або ж як вуличний фотограф.
[англійською] Завжди, коли у тебе великий фотоапарат і
ти готуєшся зробити фото: «Я зараз вас сфотографую»,
[англійською] Люди починають позувати і напружуються.
[англійською] А на малу камеру люди так не реагують.
Можна спокійно швидко наробити фото.
[англійською] Тоді виходять природні (натуральні) фото.
Живі фото.
[англійською] Ці фото справді чудові.
[англійською] Ужгород прекрасне місто.
І хоч воно маленьке, я його люблю.
[англійською] Тут є свої маленькі проблеми,
але вони не важливі.
[англійською] Маю на увазі, що західна частина України
більш європейська, люди дуже прекрасні.
– Можете подивитися на мене?
– Можна.
[англійською] Більше працюю в центрі,
там більше цікавих кадрів – цікавих людей і речей.
[англійською] У будь-якій країні є погані та добрі люди.
[англійською] Якщо я обиратиму добрих людей
та ігноруватиму поганих, то буду щасливий.
[англійською] В Індії також є люди,
яким ви не сподобаєтесь,
[англійською] але більшість все ж таки поводитимуться з вами нормально.
[англійською] Зараз в Україні нетерпимості менше.
Особливо тут в Ужгороді.
[англійською] Я дуже радий, що в Ужгороді,
у Львові – рівень нетерпимості низький.
[англійською] В Луганську –
рівень нетерпимості був дуже високий.
[англійською] Це тепер я маю багато роботи,
а перший рік було справді важко.
[англійською] Люди не знали мене,
я не знав нікого в Ужгороді.
[англійською] Мусив ходити й переконувати,
що я фотограф, що я можу добре працювати.
[англійською] Ми нічого не отримуємо від уряду.
Індія надто перенаселена і уряд не в змозі давати жодних стипендій.
[англійською] Завдяки тому, що я також працюю, я можу утримувати себе самостійно.
[англійською] Батьки сплачують лише за навчання.
[англійською] Я стараюсь дбати про себе.
[англійською] Я маю свою роботу і намагаюсь вчитись,
це трохи складно поєднувати.
[англійською] За межами Ужгорода також є багато цікавих місць.
Я багато ходжу в гори. Там гарні річки, ліси.
[англійською] Довгий час, приблизно 10-15 років,
я жив біля океану,
[англійською] а тепер от вже три роки
як живу біля гір. Це дуже різний досвід.
[англійською] Це як «океанська» частина мого життя
завершилась, почалась «гірська» частина.